ah don't you just love that new car
smell smells like power and freedom
actually it smells more like petroleum
based solvents evaporating off vinyl and
plastic Wow buzzkill let's see if you
still like that smell when you find out
what it's really costing you I'm lucky
the windows since the Auto boom of the
1950s cars have become an integral part
of American society car companies spent
fourteen point two billion dollars in
advertising alone in 2014 and that
number is only rising they convinced us
that once we're behind the wheel our
families will love us more our
neighbours will envy us and our freedom
to go anywhere is secure unfortunately
they're more likely to take away your
freedom and security new cars are a
financial triple threat we borrow money
at interest to buy an asset that do we
have to pay to maintain and here's the
big kicker that drastically depreciate
some value wait what is depreciation
anyway hey Julia would you like to buy
some ice cream sure I guess
that'll be $4 pay a nickel for that but
I just paid $4 for 20 minutes ago
that's depreciation go wash your hands
cars retain their value about as well as
ice cream on a hot day a new car will
depreciate 63 percent in the first five
years 10% of that in the moment that you
drive it off the lot
calling car is a bad investment is like
calling a honey badger a bad heart
surgeon what I mean they're not an
investment at all Oh exactly I mean can
you think of anything else that you
would spend that much money on that
loses value that quickly I don't know
how about a garage full of beanie babies
I told you the 90s are coming back sure
hon and don't think that you can get out
of this by leasing either leasing
companies set their prices so that you
pay for the depreciation of their
vehicle and when it's over they still
have an asset that they can resell so
let's set a few simple ground rules that
will put you in the driver's seat
instead of being taken for a ride
number one buy a car that's at least
five years old right away you're
skipping the majority of its
depreciation number two save up to buy a
car in cash paying interest on something
that loses value is like gaining weight
from exercise all pain no gain number
three if you can't comfortably afford to
save an equal amount to your car payment
you can't afford it so if you're not
saving $300 a month you shouldn't take
on a $300 car payment so how much money
is actually a stake I think it's time to
run the numbers
let's say I buy a new car for $20,000 I
put four thousand down and I finance the
rest over 60 months at 4.25 percent my
monthly payment will be 295 42 that's
not pretty normal but check this out
what if you bought the same car but a
five year old model which costs you
sixty three percent less or seven
thousand four hundred put your same four
thousand down and with the same loner
arrangement you're looking at a payment
of just 6278 a month that's a monthly
savings of two hundred thirty two
dollars and sixty-five cents I could get
a massage every other week with that you
could or you can take those monthly
savings and put them into a growing
asset like a home or a mutual fund and
if you continue to do that every time
you paid off the car even at a very
conservative 7% per year return in 35
years
you'd have over four hundred and twenty
thousand dollars really Wow now is that
enough to retire on probably not but
that's just one thing you can start
doing it now to prepare for your future
there are many many more you know as
much as I like that new car smell I
don't think I'd spend half a mil on now
let's try this instead hmm
what's that early retirement baby BAM
and that's our two cents
[Music]